the majority of them seem to be ending
up in the streets of New York and that
is a real problem for New York City they
create the problems and then everyone
else votes them in more and more here's
a little more of Kathy Seward because
now reality has hit her in the face and
she wants to do something about it it
can be done this can be done in a
bipartisan way comprehensive Immigration
Form whether numbers people can commit
well we want them to have a limit on who
can come across the border it is too
open right now uh people coming from all
over the world are finding their way
through simply saying they need Asylum
and the majority of them seem to be
ending up in the streets of New York and
that is a real problem for New York City
125,000 newly arrived individuals and we
are being taxed now we are always so
proud of the fact that New York has the
Statue of Liberty in our haror Harbor we
we are one of the most diverse places on
Earth because of our welcoming nature
and our it's in our DNA to welcome
immigrants but but there has to be some
limits in place and Congress has to put
more controls at the border and not in
this budget threat shown threat talk
about eliminating positions for border
patrol when we actually need to double
or quadruple those numbers so get back
to work and do your jobs what The
Border's too open but Joe and Ken
jeanpierre and everybody else always
says The Border's closed Jen saki every
day says The Border's closed it's not
open but now you have another Democrat
being like well you people are all liars
and by the way you know she's not going
to reference it but I was one of the
people pushing those lies
along